It's that time of the year again, when you head to the shops
to buy presents for family and friends...
Or maybe, like the 57% of Europeans who bought something online in 2017,
you have decided to buy gifts over the internet this year.
Ahhh, the perfect present for Uncle Erik in Stockholm...
...But wait, why can't you buy it?
Oh! It's a Spanish website!
Denial of access to goods and services online because of your location
is called Geo-blocking.
And as of December 3 rules ending the practice are applicable.
Imagine, being in Belgium, you want to buy blue jeans from a Romanian website.
You are being redirected to your Belgian website,
because in Romania they are cheaper.
Now you will not be redirected any more.
For your own use, you can buy those jeans from cheaper websites
in different countries and nobody will prohibit you to do so.
Geo-blocking is not the only form of online discrimination covered by the rules.
Not accepting credit cards from other EU countries
and not being able to register on a website based on where you live
will also come to an end...
And the legislation applies to a wide range of goods and services,
such as domestic appliances, online services like web domain hosting
and entertainment tickets for concerts or theme parks.
So this Christmas, wherever you live,
you'll no longer have any excuses for not finding the perfect present
for that special someone!